it's not been a good few years for
Facebook dogged by scandals over fate
news
data security graphic content and teen
mental health the man recently brought
in to head up communications may well
have felt he had his work cut out in a
speech in Berlin he launched a charm
offensive here's a newsflash Facebook
wants to be regulated a punchy opening
line promising to play ball the
decisions in front of us cannot and
should not be left to private companies
alone governments and policymakers must
engage proactively to there was also a
series of defenses on other issues
algorithms aren't designed to push
extreme content he said and there was no
Russian interference in the EU
referendum I understand on a personal
level the millions of people who are
surprised many are still dismayed by the
result of the 2016 presidential election
or at brexit and they quite
understandably want a way to explain
what has happened for many Facebook has
become the scapegoat mister clicks
hiring has been seen as an attempt to
clean up Facebook's image following
months of criticism Mark Zuckerberg laid
out earlier this year how he sees
regulation working but for MPs who
helped draft laws on online harm
Facebook is passing the buck for years
Facebook have said will regulate
ourselves they've shown that they can't
be trusted to regulate themselves
they're now saying government coagulates
us but in the meantime they're not
accepting any responsibility for what
their platform actually facilitates and
enables we were expecting mr. Cleg to
address Facebook's role in teen mental
health it's been an issue much in the
spotlight
in a pre published version of the speech
he was due to say that increases in
mental health problems are not linked to
social media it's an area where the
platform's been fiercely criticized and
where many think they could be doing
much more and for young people who use
it daily the pressures are still varied
and constant are we pages that they'll
be like not glamourizing so far but it
becomes like a culture it is a negative
sometimes by the same time that's the
world some may argue today was about
avoiding calls for the breakup of social
media giants to be seen to be addressing
its problems but for Facebook all new
tech has teething problems it insists it
is learning and it is changing Helen
Anne Smith Sky News